IAN ELLISON-TAYLOR: All right.
I see the clock counting
down, so I guess
we should get started.
First of all, thank you for
coming this late on a Friday.
I'm quite impressed
with the turnout.
I can't believe this
many people had
nothing better to do.
Anyways, thank you for coming.
I hope everyone has had good
I/O. This is the fireside chat
for Chrome, so this is your
opportunity to have one last
shot to ask us questions
before we
all turn into pumpkins.
Things that have come up over
through I/O or things are on
the top of your mind.
We'll quickly run through
just who we are.
And something of a tradition
for fireside chats is we
usually begin with what each of
us is most interested in,
in terms of an upcoming feature
or what's on the top
of our mind.
So we'll do that, and hopefully
that will inspire
some of you to hit the mics
and ask us questions.
Otherwise, it's just going to
be us talking for about 40
minutes, which probably isn't
going to be that interesting.
So definitely get your
questions ready.
I'm Ian Ellison-Taylor.
I'm the director of product
management for the web
platform part of Chrome.
I think we've already--
trying to think of the
top features as I
look down the line.
I think we've already hit,
probably, my favorite in the
keynote, which is Web Components
and the tool kit,
just simply for what I think it
will allow folks like you
to be able to do over the next
year, much more easily than
you've been able to do.
So I think that's going
to be my top feature.
So I will pass the mic.
LARS BAK: I'm Lars Bak.
I'm a software engineer
at Google.
And my favorite feature I look
forward to is speed.
And that'll come to you
in the form of Dart.
GREG SIMON: Hi, I'm
Greg Simon.
I'm managing director
for Blink.
And my most anticipated feature
that I can't wait to
see is the lazy-block layout.
ERIK KAY: Hi, Erik Kay.
I'm the instructor for Apps and
Extensions Native Client.
And I too am really excited
about Web Components.
I think it's been this huge gap
in the web platform that
were finally going to fill in,
and really make the web an
equal to other tool
kits out there.
DARIN FISHER: Hi, my name's
Darin Fisher.
I'm an eng lead on Chrome.
And by far the thing that I'm
most excited about is
performance, and I'm really
excited about what we're doing
to give you all back the main
thread and de-jank the
browser, make the rendering
engine much, much, much faster
and more responsive.
MATT MCNULTY: Hi, I'm
Matt McNulty.
I lead the polymer team.
And I'm most excited about Web
Components as well. 'cause
without them, we're dead.
[LAUGHTER]
JEFF CHANG: Hello.
Wow.
My name is Jeff Chang, and
I am a product manager on
Chrome's UI features
and releases.
And one of the things that I'm
most excited about personally
is WebRTC, particularly
on mobile.
I think the notion that you can
use your phone and fire up
a browser and just go to a
website and immediately be
able to video chat with
someone else, without
installing any plug-ins
or what not, I
think that's amazing.
VANGELIS KOKKEVIS: And I'm
Vangelis Kokkevis.
I'm the engineering lead for the
Chrome GPU team, for the
folks who take care of rendering
performance in
Chrome, including GPU
accelerating or rendering, and
some of the 3D APIs that we
currently have in Chrome.
And then I'll echo what
most people said here.
Performance is really what
we're after here.
IAN ELLISON-TAYLOR: Uh, we've
also got other members of the
Chrome team and other parts
of Google sitting in the
audience, as well.
So hopefully, we can answer
questions in any sort of area
that might be on your mind.
We have a couple of folks,
I see, from Adobe.
And Bruce, as well, from
Opera, who's on hand to
answer, maybe, if there are
general questions about web
standards, maybe get an
outside perspective.
I'm more than happy to hand
over the mic to Bruce and
others if people
have questions.
So with that, let's
get started.
First question.
Who wants to go first?
AUDIENCE: Hi, guys.
I was wondering why Chrome was
not the default browser and
web view in Android, and if
there is any light at the end
of the tunnel with that.
IAN ELLISON-TAYLOR: Who's most
qualified to answer that?
Darin?
DARIN FISHER: Well, I can just
say that that's something
that's being worked on.
You can see, if you go to
chromium.org, that there is an
Android WebView project
that can be built from
the Chromium sources.
It's a project that of course
we're really interested in.
I think Chrome is, our team is
all about making the web
platform better, and we want to
make sure that that extends
to the WebView that's available
on Android.
IAN ELLISON-TAYLOR: Yeah, and I
think just as time goes on,
the plan, we hope, is that
you'll see WebView and Chrome
increasingly become the default
on newer devices.
There's work to be
done, I think.
AUDIENCE: Since there aren't
many people standing, I
thought maybe I'd ask
one more question.
IAN ELLISON-TAYLOR:
All right, sure.
AUDIENCE: I kind of see the
future of web IDs as being in
the user agents themselves,
and I think the Chrome
DevTools kind of realize this
vision the most out of any
sort of developer suite.
But it's not really quite there
yet, when you compare it
to things like Coda
and Sublime Text.
But it seems to be pushing
further and further in that
direction every year.
And I was wondering what the
team's philosophy or intent
was in this area.
IAN ELLISON-TAYLOR: Lars, are
you closest to DevTools?
ERIK KAY: I'll take a swing.
So unfortunately, Pavel's
not here.
But I mean, if anybody's been
following the progress of
Chrome DevTools over the last
couple years, I think the
changes they've made, the rate
of change is just amazing.
You check back every few months,
and it's like some
huge, awesome new feature
has landed.
And so this time around, yeah,
they did land code editing,
local code editing.
And so that's a new feature.
And since it's just added and
just showing up, I think it's
early days.
And so yes, they definitely want
to make it possible for
people to do end-to-end
development and to take care
of all the debugging needs, from
memory profiling to sort
of timeline rendering
performance--
I think end-to-end, they want
to do the whole thing.
And the other bit of philosophy,
by the way, just
from the team's perspective
is they don't--
even though they want to build
it into the browser so it's
there by default, they want to
make it possible for other
tools to integrate as well.
So everything that's done in
Chrome DevTools is done via an
open protocol, a network
protocol, that
anyone can plug in to.
And you see that a number
of IDEs are doing this.
From the JetBrains guys, to
Eclipse, to whatever, they all
now talk to the Chrome
debugging tools.
And basically, they can
use all the same
features that we add.
GREG SIMON: Certainly in the
short term, you're going to
see the team focus more on tools
to help you find and fix
jank and deal with memory, so.
AUDIENCE: Thank you guys.
AUDIENCE: Thank you for making
web faster with Chrome.
And my question is back
to WebView in Android.
Like once you make Chrome
default one, how [INAUDIBLE]
have a rapid release
cycle for that?
DARIN FISHER: Well, I will just
say that I think we are
all very interested in getting
to a point where the WebView
is something that could
be auto-updated.
It's the kind of thing that
definitely, that we dream and
imagine, wouldn't
that be nice?
So it's definitely the kind of
thing, you know, coming from
the Chrome team, this is
something that's very--
this is how we look
at software.
I mean, Chrome has this kind
of auto-update cycle.
It would make sense for the
WebView to have that as well.
AUDIENCE: Hey there.
I'm a release manager for
Firefox, so just full
transparency.
I'm really curious to know
about your releases, your
stability, and if there's
anything you're planning to do
to open up crash data for public
viewing, as a way that
we could maybe even know if
there's common crashes we're
experiencing on the
web in general.
It looks like you already
anonymize the data, so is that
something that you might
open up at some point?
And actually, a follow-up to
that is, I'm just curious if
the recent dip in Chrome
adoption, is
all related to stability?
Are there any opinions
on that?
JEFF CHANG: Hi, so first
of all, thank
you to Firefox for--
I think the fact that you guys
moved to a faster release
cycle is great for the web and
great for users in general.
On the crash data thing, I'll
definitely look into that.
I'll talk with our release
managers about that.
I actually had Adobe asking a
similar question recently, and
so we'll see what we can do.
And the last point, we actually
haven't seen any dip
in user adoption, so.
ERIK KAY: So one other
thing about that--
it turns out the crash data,
that even if you anonymize it,
it has personally identifiable
information in it.
It'll be a URL.
It'll be maybe form contents
of the page.
It'll be that sort of thing.
So actually, it turns out that
crash data is very sensitive.
It's not the sort of thing that
we can sort of easily
give out on that front.
The other big problem
with crash data is
that crashes are almost--
well, a large percentage of
crashes are a pointer to
potential security problems.
If there's a crash, that
probably means that there's
some exploit behind it, quite
often, I should say.
And that's another reason why
until we've tracked down the
source of that crash, we
probably can't make it public.
Now it's possible that things
like crash rates and stability
and changes on that front are
something that we could do, or
maybe even pointing at
modules or individual
areas of the product.
But in terms of actually getting
the crash data out
there and making it available,
I don't think that something
we'll be able to do.
GREG SIMON: Right, but like
pointing at SVG wouldn't
actually tell you anything
useful, right?
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: I have a question
about Netflix.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: On the Chromebook
Pixel, which I've been using
for a while, the LTE version,
in the stable channel,
everything works great.
There are times I've noticed
that whenever the Pixel gets
hot, it'll downgrade the
CPU, and the video
quality will go down.
But what I don't understand is
in the developer and beta
version, the video quality is
really poor, regardless of the
bandwidth connection,
or regardless of
my settings on Netflix.
I've asked around while I've
been here, and I haven't been
able to find a clear-cut
answer of why.
I know whenever I'm using Chrome
on my Windows computer,
and I hit Shift-Control-Alt-S, I
have the ability to manually
select the speed at which
it's playing the video.
But I don't know a combination
on for Chrome OS.
But my goal in my question is,
how do I get my video quality
back up to HD?
[LAUGHTER]
DARIN FISHER: Well, I mean, I
don't know that we necessarily
have experts here who know
exactly all the details there.
So it's possible you're
just seeing a
bug in the beta channel.
It's also possible that you're
seeing the effects of the
changes to the player.
I'm not really sure.
I think we'd have
to look into it.
GREG SIMON: Yeah.
The other thing is, you
know, we have these
channels for a reason.
When I first got my first
Chromebook, I was living on
dev channel, and there were some
days where it just didn't
quite work at all.
So now I live on beta.
We do use these channels
to do experiments.
Well, at least the [INAUDIBLE]
in dev.
DARIN FISHER: I would really
encourage you to file a bug.
Actually, don't assume that
just because you're seeing
something that seems wrong in
beta channel, don't assume
that everybody else
is seeing it too.
So we really appreciate
bug reports.
AUDIENCE: Yes, I had one--
one was filed for me
earlier today.
DARIN FISHER: Excellent.
AUDIENCE: While I was
asking the question.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Quick question
about Bluetooth.
It's cool to see Chrome getting
Bluetooth support.
Is it also going to get
Bluetooth LE support?
ERIK KAY: I don't know
if anybody here is--
we don't have any Chrome
OS hardware guys here.
But I believe so.
I mean, I think that that's a
fairly new emerging standard,
and I know people who
are playing with it.
I just don't know what any
timeline or any products in
particular.
DARIN FISHER: Mention
Chrome [INAUDIBLE].
ERIK KAY: Oh yeah.
The reason Darin handed the mic
to me is that we do have
APIs, that we are part of Chrome
packaged apps, that
allow you to write apps to talk
to Bluetooth devices.
No LE support in there either,
but definitely, you can
integrate with hardware
from your apps.
AUDIENCE: Right.
And those APIs are actually
pretty good.
So thanks.
ERIK KAY: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi there.
I had a question about
release cycles.
And I think that the rapid
release cycle that's been
adopted initially by Chrome and
kind of carried on to some
other browsers as well has
really accelerated the rate at
which we're seeing some great
new features show up.
The way we end up kind of
deciding what we feel safe
targeting now, because there is
still somewhat of a tail of
people-- how long
it is varies--
who are on older versions of
assorted browsers, we kind of
pick features that we feel are
in the majority of browsers,
and then we look and see, OK,
how much can we fill in using
JavaScript?
And if we have to support
something really far back, how
much can we fill in by drinking
ourselves into a
stupor and pretending that
feature doesn't exist?
Do you think that going forward,
we're still going to
see the main way in which we get
new features for people on
older browsers is through
JavaScript fill-in?
Or do you think that there might
be some way we could
find a way to approximate
features outside of
JavaScript, and maybe something
natively supported
in the browser?
GREG SIMON: I mean, there are
some things that just can't be
polyfilled, right?
I mean, like we're doing a
project right now called the
Navigation Controller, which
involves a script running when
a URL request is made
in the browser.
I'm not sure exactly how to
polyfill that, so for that,
we're just going to actually
implement it, plant a flag.
But yeah.
ERIK KAY: I think if you took
a look at the work that the
Polymer team has done--
I used to be pretty skeptical
about polyfills.
I told them they were crazy to
try to polyfill Shadow DOM,
for example.
And I think they even agreed
with me when they were
trying to do it.
But yet somehow, they actually
managed to do it, and to get
pretty darn close.
And so I think JavaScript
polyfills are actually an
important way forward.
I'll toss out a plug for another
polyfill approach,
which can work with other
types of features.
Which is at least within Chrome,
we can experiment and
prototype new features
with Native Client.
So for example, one of the
things that Darin has pointed
out repeatedly is if in the
past, we had Native Client, we
might have been able to, say,
prototype Web SQL without
having to add it
to the browser.
And we would have learned quite
a bit about what people
thought about it, and probably
wouldn't have needed to have
implemented it to begin
with at that point.
So I think that when you have a
big pile of native code and
you want to use that as a way to
add features, we don't have
to worry about rewriting it from
scratch in JavaScript.
We can still do polyfills
that way as well.
DARIN FISHER: Yeah, I'll just
say that general issue
definitely encourages us to
focus on identifying the best
primitives, the simplest
primitives that we can add to
the platform, that give us the
most value-add that allows us
to make the polyfills
work well.
For example, there's
a lot of discussion
about pointer events.
And we have a polyfill for
pointer events, but it's
missing one little piece,
which is the
touch-action CSS property.
So instead of biting off the
whole pointer events spec up
front, we're focusing
just down on the
touch-action CSS property.
Because that's the thing that we
actually have to put in the
engine in order to make the
polyfill actually have you
full fidelity.
And once we do that, it turns
out separating that
touch-action CSS property is
actually generally useful.
It's useful outside of the
context of pointer events.
It's useful as a way to-- well,
by the way, if you add a
touch event handler to your
page, you generally put the
browser in a slow path.
But the touch-action CSS
property lets you give the
browser a little more
information about this.
And so it's a useful property,
all by itself.
And so that whole idea of
focusing on primitives really,
really works out nicely,
I think.
It's worked out for things like
MDV, where we decided to
do mutation observers instead
of the full thing up front.
We added object.observe in a
similar fashion to help make
MDV work better, the
model-driven views, which is
leveraged by a polymer
quite extensively.
Don't know if you have anything
to add, Matt.
MATT MCNULTY: I was going to
bring up object.observe.
DARIN FISHER: Oh, I stole
your thunder.
AUDIENCE: Great, thank
you very much.
AUDIENCE: Hi, my question
is about scrolling.
And using Chrome on different
platforms--
like Mac, Linux, Windows,
and Android--
I notice there's kind of a big
gap in scrolling performance.
It's not always consistent.
It's not always as smooth as
it could be or perhaps as
other browsers are.
So I was curious, like how much
of that is under control
by the Chrome browser, and how
much is kind of determined by
the platform?
And maybe what areas are being
looked at, in terms of
scrolling performance.
VANGELIS KOKKEVIS: So a lot
of it is indeed us.
We are in this strange state
where we have a number of
architectures are evolving over
time, but they haven't
been fully pushed out in all
the platforms we have.
So for example, on Android,
we're sort of on the
cutting-edge scrolling
architecture, where we want to
be, which is heavily
multi-threaded.
And we can do a lot of work
outside the main thread.
And then if you go backwards,
Chrome OS is in sort of the
next step, and then Windows.
So we have threaded scrolling
on Windows, Chrome OS, and
Android with a slightly
different version.
And Mac is in a slightly
older model.
So our goal throughout the rest
of this year is really to
bring all the platforms at the
same point, and address
scrolling performance problems
once and for all.
GREG SIMON: If you have
questions about scrolling from
your own code, I strongly
encourage you to go see Nat
Duca and Tom Wiltzius' talk
from yesterday, called
"Jank--" What's it called?
It's got jank in the title.
DARIN FISHER: Go to
jankfree.org.
GREG SIMON: Yeah.
Yeah.
It's really, really good.
It'll explain exactly
how people
fall into these pitfalls.
AUDIENCE: My question
is about extensions
and their save data.
At the keynote, we heard about
the possibility of Android
being able to save the data
from device to device.
But with Chrome, whenever I sign
into a new machine, it
downloads all my extensions,
which is great.
But all my preferences
don't come over.
Is there something that would
allow kind of the same way
that Android does that, so that
those preferences would
go into Chrome and then
travel with me?
Or is that sort of on the
extension developer's end?
ERIK KAY: So we were
there first.
[LAUGHTER]
ERIK KAY: No, seriously, a year
ago, we added an API to
Extensions called Chrome
Storage Sync.
And it's really simple.
It's key value, very similar to
local storage, but async.
And it uses the Chrome
sync engine.
So it's a great way to store
settings and preferences, and
we encourage all extensions
and apps to use it.
Within Packaged we, also have
another sync mechanism called
sync file system.
Sync file system allows you to
use things like documents and
media files and that sort of
thing, and to easily do
file-based synchronization
across machines.
And it uses your Drive
account to do that.
And so with apps, not only do
you bring your settings and
your state with you, but you can
also bring your documents
with you wherever you go, so
that those will be synced
offline automatically, without
you as the app developer
having to build any server
infrastructure at all.
So the tools are all there.
But because they weren't there
from day one, what you'll find
is that there are some older
extensions, or perhaps
extension authors who just
aren't aware of the feature,
who haven't done it.
And so definitely just bug your
favorite extension author
to add the feature.
It's really easy.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'd like to know if you have
any plans on releasing a
64-bit version for Mac.
Just because of Java,
and you know.
JEFF CHANG: Yep, we're
working on it.
[LAUGHTER]
ERIK KAY: Yeah, It's hard to
get all the things right,
particularly with plug-ins.
I mean I think on
Mac, it's more
straightforward than others.
But on Windows, for those of you
who would ask the obvious
following question, it turns
out it's a much harder
problem, because most
plug-ins are 32-bit.
And so you have to do this
32-to-64-bit bridge.
And anyway, there's a lot of
other fun, interesting things.
JEFF CHANG: Yeah, I mean, I'm
not just giving lip service.
We are actually working on it.
I exchanged an email with
Adobe in the last week.
We're working on it for
Flash, as well.
And so it's definitely actively
being worked on by
engineers on our team.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
DARIN FISHER: And there's a
lot of excitement on the
Chrome team for 64-bit.
It allows us to improve
security.
it allows us to improve
performance in some
respects, for sure.
Also, though, there's the risk
of hurting performance because
we end up using more memory.
Things are just, they end up
taking up more space because
they're 64-bit pointers
and so on.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Yes, I used
to use Netscape.
Anybody remember that?
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: And it became a kind
of slow and bloated over time,
and I switched to Phoenix, which
became Firebird, which
became Firefox.
And that became kind of overly
large and bloated over time,
and so I switched to Chrome.
And over the past few months,
I've noticed, especially with
lots of tabs--
I keep dozens of them open--
it's been getting slower
and slower.
And I'm wondering what
steps that you'll
take in general to--
as computers become faster,
there's a tendency to optimize
for the current, whatever
the newest one is.
What steps do you take to make
sure it doesn't become slower
and slower and more bloated
on existing computers?
LARS BAK: I'll go first.
I used to work on V8 team.
And I think we did a good job in
making performance better,
and that translates to
old machines, too.
If you had an old machine, it
will run faster with a better
[INAUDIBLE] engine.
But at the same time, we spend
a lot of time profiling
applications and reducing memory
footprint by tuning the
garbage collector so the total
footprint for the app would
stay minimal.
Again, we are not the only ones
at fault here, right?
Because the application
developers, they also put in
code in the browser that
allocates objects.
And of course, when they get
more modern machines, they
write more code and
it penalizes the
people using the browser.
So certainly, we are trying all
the time to minimize the
amount of memory
used by a tab.
But in some cases,
it's very hard.
Because when you have
[INAUDIBLE], it's used by the
application as well.
GREG SIMON: Yeah, I mean,
there is more than one
contributing factor
to this, right?
I mean, there's just-- there is
content you load that just
runs in the background,
and you don't know
it's running, et cetera.
And we aren't prioritizing
the processes, et cetera.
There are many, many
micro-benchmarks that we
monitor with every build
of Chrome, et cetera.
But sometimes, some piece of
content comes down that
tickles it in a certain
way that we
weren't actually measuring.
And so there are certainly areas
that we can improve, and
we are working on improving
right now in the area of
shared workers and threads
and things like that.
ERIK KAY: So the old story we
say, and some of you may have
heard us tell this
story before--
I thought Darin was going to go
with this, so I'll step on
that one for him.
When we started Chrome, when
Darin and Ben first got the
first version of Chrome up and
running-- and when I say first
version of Chrome, I mean like
no UI, just rendering a web
page really literally.
Come on, it had grey
squares for tabs.
ERIK KAY: OK, grey
So basically, people said,
well, you know what?
From today on, this won't
get any faster.
Because from now on,
we're just going
to be adding features.
And as you say, features,
it's bloat, right?
It just can't help but
slow things down.
And so how do we prevent that?
How do we keep it as fast
as it feels right now?
And the idea was that, well,
let's create a performance
benchmarks now, before
we add any features.
And let's not regress that.
Let's promise ourselves that
we will not regress those
benchmarks.
And so start-up performance
was a big one.
We wanted that to be
instantaneous.
We have a page cycler benchmark
from the early days
that also, we were very
religious about.
And so when every check-in,
effectively every check-in, we
run those tests.
And when there's a very
small regression,
we revert that change.
So even something as small
as 10 milliseconds, 20
milliseconds, that's grounds
for giving reverted.
Because those small regressions
add up over time.
Now every now and again, you
would look at something, and a
feature landed, and it caused
a regression, and you could
totally understand why it caused
a regression, but it
was for a really good reason.
And so the good news is that
by measuring it so
consistently, you could make
informed trade-offs.
There are times where you're
willing to take a small
performance hit to land
a particular feature.
But because we're religious
about measuring it all along
the way, we could make those
as informed decisions.
I think the last bit that I just
want to reinforce from
what these guys are saying is
that in some ways, we're a
victim of all the cool
performance and features we've
been adding.
That by making JavaScript
amazingly faster, and by
adding WebGL and whatever, that
people are now writing
more complex web pages.
That even the most basic things
that you were doing
before, people are doing
cooler stuff with it.
And so those 20 tabs that you
have open today are actually
doing a lot more than they were
just a few years ago.
And so that's part of it.
But I want to be clear, though,
that we're not perfect.
We do have regressions.
We do have things that happen.
And one of the things that we're
concerned about over
time is that there are things
that just happen because
people's profiles get big,
because their history ages,
because they install
more stuff.
And those are things that are
hard to test up front.
They're hard to test in the lab,
and hard to reproduce.
And so to catch those,
we tried to do field
measurements, and get aggregate
statistics, and look
for regressions in the
field on that front.
But some of these things, even
still, are hard to track down.
And so if you've got specific
things or specific pages or
whatever that you think are
just noticeably worse, or
scenarios that are noticeably
worse, please file a bug.
We take performance
very seriously.
It's really our number-one
concern.
IAN ELLISON-TAYLOR: Yeah, I just
add, just briefly on top
of that, there's definitely
those two
halves to the equation.
There's the sites that we're
loading that have changed over
time and gotten bigger, and so
that's where things like SPDY,
WebP, and other things, we hope
will speed things up a
little bit and get some of
that performance back.
And also, those usage cases
have changed over time.
And so we've been recently
looking at rebalancing some of
the code that sort of
better reflects
most typical use cases.
And I think page load time got
about 5%, something around 5%
faster just recently, because
we went and re-architected a
few things to recognize
these scenarios.
So there's still a lot more that
we can do, and those sort
of heuristics.
And also trying to get more
code out of the way at
start-up, and get rid of some of
that bloat that's crept in.
But there is also that-- using
WebP and other similar
techniques to reduce
the load so you can
have more tabs open.
So hopefully, we'll continue to
see improvements over the
months to come.
GREG SIMON: Yeah, I mean, there
are so many performance
metrics that we measure now that
it became too much for a
human to actually read.
So earlier in the year, we
borrowed some signal
processing code from Google
Search, I guess.
Sure.
To actually go through and watch
it all, and then to send
us alerts when it happens.
Because it just became
too much.
We really care about it a lot.
IAN ELLISON-TAYLOR: We very
nearly had a screenshot for
the keynote, and it got cut at
the last minute, that showed
one of the performance
dashboards that was 100
different charts that monitored
all these different
things, and some of the
alerts that went on.
It's gone.
It's very, very complicated to
look at these performance
scenarios, but we'll
keep working on it.
VANGELIS KOKKEVIS: And I also
think it's worth mentioning
that the way that technology
is moving in general, it
forces us to go and rethink some
of the core architecture
principles that we've had.
Because now instead of having
the 8, 12, 30-core machines,
we're dealing with mobile
devices with a lot more
constraints.
So a lot of the architecture
decisions we are making are to
address lower-bar devices.
And so as a side effect of that,
we're going to get older
PCs to become faster as well.
ERIK KAY: By the way, in case
it isn't obvious from the
number of people who wanted to
chime in on this one, we care
a lot about performance.
IAN ELLISON-TAYLOR: Performance
and security.
But we should probably--
I'm sorry.
DARIN FISHER: I was going
to pile on with
what Erik just said.
IAN ELLISON-TAYLOR: OK.
I was going to try
and move us on.
I'm watching that clock
count down.
OK, let's go to the next one.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hopefully this
is a quick one.
My question's about Flash.
Chrome is kind of unique in
that Flash is bundled and
updated through the browser.
I was curious how that
partnership with Adobe works,
and also if you see that as
continuing long-term or if
Flash might be phased
out in the future.
JEFF CHANG: So I can't comment
on the business partnership,
but we definitely enjoy working
with Adobe to one, as
you say, build in Flash into
Chrome, so that you get it
right off the bat.
You never have to worry
about installing it.
And two, the kind of bigger
reason we did that was so that
we could work directly with them
to get Flash inside of
Chrome Sandbox.
And so we're very happy that on
Windows and Mac and Chrome
OS, Flash is actually running
inside of Chrome Sandbox.
And so when you see news about
all these exploits, and people
getting pwned through Flash,
we've been happy that Chrome
users are protected even more
through that Sandbox.
And so because we take security
so seriously, yes, we
will definitely keep
doing that.
DARIN FISHER: Yeah, and just to
put that into perspective,
I mean, the amount of security
bugs that we
encounter in Blink--
it's ongoing.
The Sandbox is really the best
mitigation we have, as well as
our rapid auto-update,
to keep users safe.
Code is complicated.
It's easy to write bugs
that can be exploited.
And so we need belts
and suspenders.
We need ways to protect users.
And so getting Flash not just
in the Sandbox, but onto our
auto-update train means that we
can help provide users with
the best experience, and a
very secure experience.
JEFF CHANG: Yeah, I forgot to
mention the auto-update part.
So every time a new Flash
version comes out, you get it
in Chrome automatically.
You don't have to
worry about it.
AUDIENCE: Go to this side.
AUDIENCE: Hi, everybody.
One of the problems I have is
when I have a lot of tabs
open, the individual tab items
themselves get very, very
small and kind of hard
to work with.
it used to be possible to have
vertical tabs in Chrome, and I
was wondering, what are your
thoughts on vertical tabs, and
will we ever see them again?
IAN ELLISON-TAYLOR: Jeff.
[LAUGHTER]
DARIN FISHER: We can
all look at Jeff--
IAN ELLISON-TAYLOR: Yeah,
come on, Jeff.
DARIN FISHER: He was PM
for Chrome front ends.
IAN ELLISON-TAYLOR: He's backing
away from the stage.
JEFF CHANG: Yeah, yeah, OK.
And now I have another data
point, another request.
So I'll keep it in mind.
DARIN FISHER: It's been
one of these long--
things we've always talked
about, how to
manage more tabs better.
It's a very challenging topic.
ERIK KAY: We do have a wacky
idea, if you're interested in
hearing that.
A wacky idea is to provide an
extension API to just hide
tabs, to make them so they're
not even visible.
And then to give extension
authors the ability to create
their own UI surface for them.
I don't know if we'll actually
get around to doing something
like that, but it was
one wacky idea.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: My question's
regarding extensions for
Chrome, and is there any
plan to bring that
to Chrome for Android?
ERIK KAY: It's something
we've explored.
It's hard on a lot of front.
First off, as Vangelis pointed
out earlier, Android phones in
particular, I should
say, are very
constrained devices, right?
And so right now, we're
trying to make Chrome
as small as we can.
And so we're stripping as much
out as we can and still
keeping it functional.
And so we're not quite ready to
say that it's time to add
more features back
in quite yet.
But we're experimenting
with it internally.
And I think the other big
concern to think about with
extensions on mobile is mobile
is very different on a few
fronts that don't really
work all that well with
the model we've got.
So first off, there's different
UI surfaces.
There's a much smaller amount
of screen real estate.
Secondly, in these mobile
environments, things are
killed off all the time.
The browser doesn't
keep running.
When you switch to another
app, it's gone.
And one of the nice things about
extensions were things
that keep running and they
keep doing their thing.
So I think that there
are some challenges.
That even when we want to do it,
the experiments we've done
are just trying to figure
out how to make
it even make sense.
So even if we do it, it's likely
to be something that's
not 100% compatible with what
we're doing on the desktop.
That would be a different
beast altogether.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
I was curious about how you've
been using all the anonymous
user usage data you've
been getting from us.
How to make the product better,
the Chrome browser?
JEFF CHANG: Yeah, so you're
talking about, when you
install Chrome, there's an
option to opt in to anonymous
usage statistics.
And that's like button clicks
and things, and crash reports,
and stuff like that when
you're using features.
And yeah, we look at that
stuff all the time.
And recently, we've actually
improved upon that system.
I think we blogged about it.
But we have, basically, an
experimental system by which
we can push out different
versions of features to
different buckets of users.
So we do live A/B experiments
through
our auto-update system.
And then we can say, oh--
a trivial example, you know--
this many people clicked on
version A of the button versus
version B of the button
versus version C of
the button or whatever.
And we can compare metrics like
stability and feature
usage and retention of Chrome
users and stuff like that.
And then we can decide which
one we want to go with.
Of course, it doesn't make all
of our decisions for us.
We take the combination of the
data and our intuition and
stuff like that to decide
what to do.
But yeah, we definitely
look at that.
The other thing I should mention
is we only put in
stats for things--
we have to decide what to
measure, and then put in the
stats for it, and then
decide what to do.
So it's not like we're just
collecting random stats
everywhere.
GREG SIMON: We can also
use it to do-- sorry.
We can also use it to do really
short experiments.
One of my favorite examples of
this was one of the folks on
the team couldn't figure out, by
reading MSDN, what the max
file path length was.
He got at least two, maybe
three different answers.
But this is something that you
actually want to get right,
because it can lead to
strings that are out
of bounds, et cetera.
So he checked in an experiment
for like 24 hours and got the
decisive answer for it.
And then took the
actual code out.
All done in the open.
DARIN FISHER: I mean, there's
just been countless examples
of tuning Chrome by
using this system.
I mean, one of the classic
examples was figuring out how
many parallel TCP connections
to open per origin.
I mean, today, it's six, but it
used to be that the typical
number was four.
This spec says two.
I mean, what do you
choose, right?
And so by making adjustments and
measuring and looking at
the statistical data we get
back, we can make informed
decisions, and that'll make
a faster product.
The number that I think Ian
quoted, on 5% page load
performance, that kind of stuff
gets validated using
that anonymous usage data.
ERIK KAY: I think crash reports
are probably the most
useful, far and away.
I mean, what we use it for is
a quick stability check for
us, especially with Canary
and dev channel.
What we can see is release over
release, we have a stat
which we look at as crash
per million page views.
Crashes per million
page views.
And we can look at it by
different process type and
that sort of thing.
And so looking at that over
time, you can see when one
release is dramatically less
stable than another, and then
have somebody drill in.
So it sets off alarms.
And so we have as a metric, we
talked about wanting to drive
performance numbers down.
We also--
there's a fourth S that Linus
didn't mention in the keynote,
which is stability, as well,
that we take very seriously.
And we're always trying to drive
that crash per million
number down for all the
processes, for all the platforms.
And so that's another incredibly
useful bit of data.
IAN ELLISON-TAYLOR: I see that
clock counting down ominously.
I think we've probably got time
for one more question,
and then we'll take questions
outside, if
anyone can hang around.
AUDIENCE: Chrome OS Sync
FileSystem seems to be backed
only by Google Drive
right now.
Are there any plans to make that
pluggable for something
like Dropbox to be the data
store, economical cloud data
store for our Chrome
OS device?
ERIK KAY: We'd love to do it.
We're starting off with one
use case first, and really
trying to make sure
we nail it.
But yes, we'd love to make it
so that's more pluggable.
IAN ELLISON-TAYLOR: All right,
I see the last 10 seconds.
I'll take this as
an opportunity
just to thank everybody.
First, for coming to I/O, coming
to this session, and
asking such fantastic
questions.
I really appreciate it.
So give yourselves a hand
for great questions.
[APPLAUSE]
IAN ELLISON-TAYLOR: And we'll
maybe see some of you outside
if we didn't get
to answer them.
All right.